thank you for coming back we continue
this morning with someone from Mercy who
will speak about four-year presentations
in probabilistic inference okay
thanks and thanks for having me here so
this is about free a representation for
public inference I should point out it's
it's really to work off of one of our
students
en su who I think has one more year to
go but but he is really the main driver
force behind this this new work so oh
and I guess other people's stuff in
Ehrman running lebra Karla Gomes and
myself so it all starts off with sort of
thing about public reasoning and of
course the key key observation that
people use in public inference is to
have some high dementia probability
estimation but but be able to represent
it in some compact form so this leads to
do the factor grass and the graphical
models etc and this compact form allows
them for efficient inference algorithms
and machine learning with better
predictive power in generalization if
you find the right form
and all these these reputation based on
some form of Independence and then here
is the most extreme form of Independence
where you can write a a joint
probability distribution as a product
but of course there's conditional
independence and all kinds of different
forms of Independence what I want to
advocate in this talk is to use Fourier
representation of what we call bullying
pseudo boolean functions which are
really probability distributions but we
we proposed it as a novel way of
representing a high dimensional
probability distribution so my goal is
to sort of give you a flavor of what
what the free a representation can do
for you and some results on why it is a
good representation and finally some
experimental results showing it works
very well in practice so so the two key
points I'm going to show you is these
free eight you have probably have seen
some form of Fourier analysis in
continuous domains where in signal
processing where you look at the Fourier
spectrum of a signal one thing we're
going to show is that for interesting
probability distribution
most of the probability mass
concentrates on lower degree
coefficients in the Fourier spectrum
which means young free spectrum can
actually have an exponential number of
terms but will be able to cut off to the
first small polynomial number of terms
and get a good approximation of our
distributions and in fact what we'll do
in the algorithms we will actually drop
higher-order 3-8 coefficients and the
nice thing about that is we can do that
and give good approximation in terms of
l2 norm with respect to the the full
distribution and we'll get some
approximation guarantees which are much
harder to obtain with other methods like
variational approaches or mini bucket
elimination which are inference
procedures that give bounds upper bounds
or lower bounds but but generally don't
give a clear l2 and
approximation so these are the two main
properties I want to bring out so and
then we'll have the hordes of magnet on
a practical evaluation okay so very
basic and introduction so we let's say
we have a little factor of them just to
two variables all verbs are boolean we
use minus 1 plus 1 so minus 1 to
represent false personal description
true and we just have a little little
functioning of two variables so for
possible settings and these are the real
values think of Jesus as four four
numbers probabilities that end up add up
to two one for example now what we can
do so normally in inference these are
you know probability tables messages
when we have message passing algorithms
or little probability tables that are
moved around but we want to represent
this this function differently we want
to represent this dysfunction in free a
representation I'm just going to show
you how you can get what if we ate a
representation all this just for a two
variable case but it generalizes just a
little this is a linear interpolation
formula you can you can see that every
entry here so we rewrite this function
Phi XY into this form and if you just
look at the first entry minus 1 F put in
minus 1 here or 1 minus 1 minus 1 this
we fill its to 1 this evaluates for
minus 1 to village to 1 and so basically
in this first row you see that this
expression evaluates to Phi 1 okay and
actually the other one's got all
reevaluate that's the green parts and
one of them one minus one with y minus 1
will get to zero so all the other terms
disappear and similarly you can check
for all other settings that this
expression is the same as this function
ok and then you can again rewrite this
group two terms and you get terms you
know as a function of X as a function of
Y as a function of X time
why and and zero a term here with no x
and y so this is the Fourier
representation off of this little
function here and whoops
yeah so XY and and these are the Fourier
coefficients is the first Fourier
coefficient this is the the first degree
term actually pair is the basic function
ax and we have a basic function y and a
basic function X Y they start a food a
basis function and this is a value a
real number basically the coefficients
the Fourier coefficients okay
so it is a very tiny example in general
it's called the hidamari Fourier
transformation every way that function
can be uniquely expressed as a multi
linear polynomial where these are the
Fourier coefficients and these are the
Fourier basis functions which are
basically products of X Y Z etc products
of the original variables and these
products are actually parody functions
I'll give a little bit more detailed
example next so actually let's just skip
to that so so here's the the example I
just had up so this is actually the 0
degree degenerate and this is the first
degree term that has a free a base
function of X this is another first
degree term for a free a basis function
y these are parity functions x y y are
the parity function of other products of
X Y and evaluates to minus 1 if an odd
number of variables is set to minus 1
okay so that's why it's a parity
function these become XYZ very long
sequences up to full length products ok
so but we saw we rewriting the original
function in this Fourier form here we
just have up to degree two because we
just have two variables ok so and all
the coefficients are just real numbers
ok so let's think a little bit you know
what why are we doing this well the
general rubber stage is just of the
original distribution is just a table of
2 to the N
trees starting with the old - once - all
+ once - trillion numbers our food
representation will actually also be an
expression in general of 2 to the N
numbers because these basis function can
go all the way to full product basically
all subsets of variables each substance
correspond to one Fourier function or
one free a basis function so you know we
have 2 to the N term so you know on the
surface of it of course we're not
actually making any game and we could we
could obviously dismiss this but you
know why do it at all ok so what I want
to show is that this representation as
opposed to the table representation many
functions will have a few lower order
terms that is all that's needed so you
don't need these very long parity
constraints we can just do it you know
three five maybe six variables you don't
have to make very long products of
variables and the second part is you can
truncate it set all the higher order
terms to zero coefficients and then you
guaranteed that this thing still
approximate the original table quite
well in the l2 norm
okay so for the continuous case just to
do to show now this this is sort of
totally analogous and I like a studio to
continuous case for Fourier
representations so if you have a
continuous signal you can approximate it
if this was your original step function
here you can operated by a summation of
these sine functions and it gets better
in there so the first approximation just
just the first degree one approximation
of sine functions but it gets higher and
higher frequencies but the key thing is
that the coefficients of these
frequencies the hyphens become lower
smaller and smaller okay and we want
actually most of our and they call the
power spectrum most of our coefficients
we want to be focused on the first few
Fourier function
and and so so this happens in the
continuous case for many signals and
it's also gonna happen for the for the
discrete case I'm gonna try to give you
a bit of an intuition why that is but
I'm not sure I'm gonna succeed at that
so there is another way of looking at
the Fourier coefficients and that's
that's written here so that this sum is
actually key it's a sum over the parody
function that is that product of X Y Z
etc corresponds to a hyperplane in our
space and the hyperplane is kkona going
to define the function points in in
function on the right and on the left of
the hyperplane okay and the Fourier
coefficient now is going to be a sum
over the points the function values that
lie on one side minus the function
values that lie on the other side and
you can show that the formula is
equivalent to that formally defines the
if we get coefficients okay so but I
just want to not go look at the math
sort of more thinking oh if you have
this high dimensional hyper hyper cube
you're gonna put a hyperplane through it
separate your ear to set you two sets of
points and you someone up and you some
one other one and you look at the
difference okay now so if we ate
coefficients adjusting to some of the
values where you know one side of the
hyperplane and the other side of the
hyperplane okay and so what we're gonna
have is that if you have a long parity
constraints the the separation sort of
like a random cut to your space will
roughly give even weight to both sides
so these points will be total weight on
this side will be roughly centered as to
weight on that side for a long parity
constraint and because we're taking the
difference the coefficients will be
almost zero and it's actually sort of
sort of interesting because the Stephan
Erdman we'll talk later I think this
we tomorrow I think about counting and
inference using these parity constraints
and in that work we're exploiting the
fact that long parity constraints sort
of randomly cut through the space in a
balanced way we actually want that
property here we're just saying that
probably gives us near zero fourier
coefficients okay then yeah then it
doesn't work it doesn't work for all
functions yeah well actually you'll see
that very good you'll see that in the
next slide where we prove something
about what we want from a function the
parity function is indeed a bad example
for this thing oh yeah yeah very good
function is also you know that that fear
about doing shallow circuits from
circuits yeah exactly so a proof will be
based on hosta switching lemma that
actually exploits that property so yeah
so that comes out of the boolean
function of work so I'll show in a
moment okay
so yeah so if you if your function is a
single long parity function that all the
all the coefficients will go for that
parity function but let's hope the world
is not like that thank you
so so most function high order
correlations are rare okay
therefore the way difference of degree a
correspond lung parity forms are usually
small another way I like to say that you
know the Fourier exposes small groups of
variable interactions if the function if
your probability solution indeed you
know it's based on small sets of
variables that interact and that they
are have the most effect on the
probability distribution the Fourier
coefficients will bring that out okay
and that's that's what we're hoping for
so let me skip to this next as I said
we're going to at some point drop higher
higher order terms and and so to do that
we're actually going to introduce the
notion of a Fourier spectrum being
epsilon concentrated on degree up to
okay look at the degree of the parody
function up to some lengths K and and
look at the sum of the remain of all the
coefficients which on the higher degree
terms okay and we say fully experienced
after long concentrating on degree up to
K if this sum is not too big if this sum
is actually quite small less than some
some values from small value epsilon
okay if that's the case we said if we
8-quart spectrum is concentrated and
this is of course the kind of free
expression we like that has little over
here but I guess it's not all it's not
always the case that it's there but but
now so let's see what functions so what
I'm now claiming and it's sort of the
central technical result the tail burns
lead to good approximation when the
Fourier space open concern we can drop
higher and term and get a good
guaranteed boundary accuracy of the
approximation in total to distance so we
can actually dropped it if if our
function it's like that this is very
small we can drop them get a good
approximation that's that proved X is
not that hard it's formally but but I'm
not I don't want to go into the formal
leads but that's a fairly
straightforward thing to show okay so
that's good we can get rid of the higher
order terms this is is the more
interesting result and way harder to
proof so many interesting distribution
have bound a degree Fourier spectrum
have this this this low tail was very
low probability mass okay so formally so
um let me just bring up a little picture
okay so if your probability distribution
is of a certain form so you have yeah
you have a few terms if you values that
that are r1 or or can be normalized to
one and you have a bit of a gap to the
between those valleys and the second
second lowest values so this gap there
should be some gap here if we have that
gap in our distribution we would call
the competitive gap which gap 1 minus
epsilon this is this difference is 1
just a gap difference if your
distribution has that property so
there's a gap between the maximum and
second value and and and the second
level values then we can prove this
result and I will not say all the
details of the result but we can show
that the free expression is excellent
concentrated with a four factor grasp of
some bounded which does mean defectors
have effortless a certain maximum number
of variables in each factor okay now to
prove this was not easy but it comes
from extending results and this is
related to the boolean function
observation of the of the hashing
switching lemma where people it's used
to show show lower bounds for boolean
functions
it's very nice results showing that that
if you take a CNF and you randomly set
some variables in that CNF then with a
good probability the remaining formula
becomes a small decision tree and the
proof now shows that that small decision
tree can be written as a with a few
Fourier coefficients of low order okay
and we can bound the probability of it
going wrong so we can show that you know
the fraction of cases where there is no
small decision tree remaining is is is
vanishingly rare yeah that's a good
question I will have to actually look at
that
it should but I have to look at it well
it was just Oh actually double that look
that will do it here it has to be
bounded with so each factors to think of
your your probability solutions effector
graph each factor has only up to K
variables in it
there's bundle and that answers your
question I like that yeah
luckily bounded with so it's only up to
some with K so you can't do large for
parity functions okay
and so was another comment so and I left
you know the a Shang had had to fool
proofs but but I was actually decided to
spare you the details on a number
slicing knife deleted those slides but
it's a it's a clever construction of
course that you know that that how think
switching one by itself is a very nice
result so generalizing at tooties pseudo
boolean functions is an interesting way
of doing it and the key thing is you get
to this after your random restriction
you get to these small decision trees
and small decision trees come it's not
hard to show they have short they're
free coefficients or low degree and and
that's what we are exploiting and that's
what what the a Shang did for this
result okay okay okay so since we don't
have the proof you'll just go go on you
know ultimately we want to use this or
we did use it in variable elimination in
inference reasoning strategy and we're
actually going to use it to do to
calculate partition functions and now
we're just going to use so we're gonna
represent during our calculation process
now we're going to represent probability
distributions in the Fourier domain but
while we're doing at the elbow renowned
and drops higher order terms and and
because of these result of our summation
that's still a good approximation we can
do that okay so very very quick little
one variable elimination so you have
your factors here and you want to
compute your some of these function
values over all settings of a B and C
and D and a variable the nation strategy
starts doing it by picking a fixed order
on your variables and then eliminating
variables in your sum in this order okay
so a very little example we can
eliminate a by looking at the terms at
half a okay you get you get this sum we
rewrite it as GPC because it summed out
the a value and then we work with the
sum on the reduced number of variables
okay that's a very basic strategies of
course exact the problem is if you have
you know let's say a occurred also in F
a and D so in more and more factors than
these new functions start growing and
growing so they have more and more
variables to get larger and larger
tables so in inference that's the
problem that's one exactly inference
that these these sup results start
becoming larger and larger sets of
values this is actually not a good
example cuz it only have we only have
two values left two variables left but
in general if imagining if a F a comedy
here there you have G BC and D and etc
so these things start growing so a lot
of the approximation algorithm or a lot
of inference items like mini bucket
inference approach whereby rina director
you know limits the size of the number
of the size of these tables by by
truncating them effectively okay
we are not going to truncate these tails
we're gonna use the free a
representation and drop the higher order
terms okay okay so we're actually going
to do to two things we're gonna the
tables become too large in general
inference so we keep the free HR
reputation and we looked at two
different ways one is just keeping the
lowest order terms around so don't have
high parity terms in our inference or
look at the terms that have the high
just absolute value and so only keep the
keep their fourier coefficients around
it that have high values and because of
the weight concentration the Fourier
representation removing high over the
term should preserve will give us a
guarantee in l2 distance with respect to
our original distributions okay so let's
let's just give the results okay
so this was a new a our inference
challenge and the whole idea is to to
calculate partition functions I don't
quite know which what are the names of
the problems but this is the mini Booker
bucket algorithm and this is our these
are create results we look at the
absolute difference between the log 10
of the our approximation of partition
function of the exponential some - exact
value so for this for this challenge
problems they do have a ground true that
the problems are just of the right size
to be able to do the ground truth and it
can be done in 2 hours with an exact
matter so we know the ground truth here
but these results are all computed in
minutes ok so that's sort of the
contrasting exactly matters so 2 hours
these results of 20 minutes ok
but look at some of the differences so
you know you see you see things going
from from 26 down to 10 to the minus 3
you know 5 2010 to minus 6 so these
difference between be the the the true
version and the approximations become
very very small ok we looked at a number
of this is disbelief propagate sorry
many bugs also an approximation yes yeah
it's an unfortunate so this should the
exact values would all be 0 we compare
it to a true value for the for the
approximate
the full year what 3.19 one is the so
we're looking at the log base ten of the
approximation result obtained by mini
buckets mine is a log base ten of the
true value and if we take the absolute
value of that okay and that is three
point nine one okay if there were the
same this would be zero okay so this
becomes yes the quality of the
approximation and we want the number to
be as small as possible ideally we want
it to be zero okay yeah so smaller is
better yeah exactly
yeah and again so these are problems
where they can just pour the challenge
they needed to have the ground truth so
this is ones where you can just get at
the ground truth we have other results
in computer vision and some other
applications where we no longer know the
ground truth but I find that solvers
will hard to talk about it because we
don't quite know how good the
approximation is yes I don't think
anything's actually I don't I don't know
I guess then we would have to ask you
Shang so I think you didn't do anything
particular special yeah it's some
heuristic yeah so probably just similar
probably the same as many buckets picked
yeah so okay yeah so we see these
numbers you know again so it's close to
zero as possible that's what we want
okay and and we see slight difference
between if you take the maximum
coefficients versus the minimum only in
the low degree terms I think this is
slightly better than this one the bold
ones are the best numbers we got so
these are all approximation methods by
the way so a JK will go there so H okay
was the award-winning solver I think of
two years ago or last year with just a
portfolio of state-of-the-art solvers so
I think variational methods and and
really I think it picked the right
variational method you know MCMC I guess
it it found the probability of this of
the configuration God where were so low
that didn't you know didn't find any
reasonable probability so it's a little
odd but yeah so if you have some hard
constraints or some extreme probability
I'm Jim she actually has trouble finding
any good states so and belief
propagation you know actually does you
know reasonable some some values but
then gets pretty bad here so so we were
quite encouraged by this because because
it really is the best approximation by
several word of magnitude so so and the
reason you know the student you know
Chiang thought of this I guess he worked
for a while was his mini bucket of
approaches is an exact algorithm but
when tables get too big there's some
heuristic of how to prune the table and
and he looked at that and said that's
not a very principled approach like the
Phooey coefficients is a much more
principled way you drop higher four-year
terms
so so and that intuition comes out that
you know they're doing similar inference
strategy variable in nature strategy but
the better approximations of the
intermediate distributions okay and good
so so I hope I have given you some idea
that this free a transfer absent ation
can be very useful to do high
dimensional probability distribution and
and can give compact representations
number of nice properties we could show
that for factor graph is limited with
factors the probability mass just
concentrate on low degree coefficients
very nice proof here the Haas thing
switching lemma and we can also show
that if you drop the higher coefficients
you still have a good approximation l
2-norm assuming that the the tail is not
too fat of the higher or the
coefficients and then finally a
validation by actually doing this this
evaluation on the on the you a I
challenge problems for partition
functions and going and seeing how you
get much better approximations and then
the other
that's it thank you yeah